so let's talk about body mass index bmi
this is a term that's often
discussed and so let's first figure out
how it's calculated how do we figure
this out so if you have a little stick
person
what you could do is have them step on a
scale
and you get their weight so the first
thing you need is their weight
and then you go on and you ask them if
they would mind if you would take their
measurement of height and so you get
their h or height
and a bmi is basically just taking
those two numbers
and using them in a little equation
where you take the weight divided by the
height
squared
very simple right
so now
let me calculate my bmi but before i do
that i have to tell you one more thing
which is that the weight this is in
kilograms kg
and the height is actually in meters
squared
so
when i was actually figuring out my own
height and weight i realized the problem
and i'll show you what that was so my
weight
is 160 pounds
and my height
is six foot
one inch
which is the same as 73 inches
so i would love to use this easy
equation but i have pounds and inches i
don't have kilograms and meters so what
do i do
well
what i need to do first is is convert
over right so i can say all right well
one pound
one pound
equals and this is something you can
just look up on the internet
0.454
kilograms
so far so good
and now one inch which is pretty small
is going to be a small number relative
to a meter which is huge right and so
it's it is it's 0.0254
meters
so now i've got my conversions
and actually what i can do is i can take
these numbers
and plug them in here
to help me easily convert from kilos and
meters over to pounds and inches make my
equation much simpler for me to use so i
could say okay
well now how about weight
in pounds
and
height
in inches
squared
and i have to multiply right because i
have to multiply by the conversion and
so i'll multiply by 0.454
divided by
0.025
squared
and to make it even easier i can
actually take this whole thing
plug it into my calculator
and it gives me the number 703
so i can say okay so really what i have
here is
again weight in pounds
divided by height
in inches
squared
multiplied by 703.
so going back now i can finally throw in
my own numbers right i can say okay so
my bmi
is 160
divided by
73
times
let me write that out 73
squared times
actually
times 703
so
let me erase that just to make it clear
okay
so this math works out to
21. so my bmi is 21.
wonderful
the next question is well what does that
mean you know if i have a bmi of 21 is
that
normal or is that good or how should i
feel about that
so if you put a
scale out here
starting with 0 to let's say 30
and i have 25 here
and let's say this is about 18.5
what physicians have done is basically
divide up the bmi into categories and
they said okay well if your bmi as an
adult is somewhere between 0 and 18.5
somewhere in this range
i'm going to do it in yellow
then you're underweight i'm just going
to write under
and if you're between 18.5 and 25 if
you're in this range
you're
in a very healthy range
and so i'll write a little smiley face
for that
and if you're above 25 let's say 25 to
30
then you're in the overweight range
and finally if you're above 30 let's say
you're out here
then you're obese
and so that's where the word obese
really
comes from it comes from a category of
bmi
and so going back to my bmi i'm
right here at 21 and i'm doing pretty
well
but
the question might come up in my head
you know what weight uh would i be if i
was overweight and what weight would i
be if i was obese you know how many
pounds away am i from being in those
categories
so i can go back to my equation
bmi equals w over h squared and i can
just rearrange it i could say okay well
how about w
equals
bmi
times h squared
over
703 right because that's the conversion
so if i rewrite the equation like this
then now i can solve for my weight i can
say okay well let's say that i wanted to
figure out what to do if i have a bmi of
25
and i know that
my height probably won't change
i'm not going to grow anymore
and 703 is the number we always have to
use when we're using the conversion from
pounds to kilos and inches to meters
so what does that equal
well in this particular case
using 25 i can see that for me to be
overweight i would be around 190 pounds
190 pounds
so that's actually really really good to
know that's actually 30 pounds above
what i am today so that gives me a sense
for how far away i am from being
overweight
and i can even do this for
a bmi of 30. i can say what about a bmi
of 30
my current
height again is 73 inches that's not
going to change
and i can do the math and find out that
in this case my
weight would be 227 pounds
so if i was 227 pounds given my height i
would be considered obese